pues son nominados que pues serán
precisamente más fáciles el de aprobar
en un eventual de senado de mayoría
republicana son personas que tienen
reconocimiento interno externo son
veteranos de obama y también obviamente
muy cercanos a jobvite en le doy cinco
nombres que han llamado mucho la
atención el primero de ellos alejandro
mayorkas te lo mencionaba un cubano
cuando cumplió un año se vino a vivir a
eeuu fue subdirector del departamento de
seguridad nacional de eeuu en la
administración de obama y ahora será el
primer latino en ser director de el
departamento de seguridad nacional
departamento que administra el tema
migratorio en eeuu el segundo nombre es
janet yellen y es que en plena crisis
económica es bastante importante el
nombre de ellas una experimentada
economista laboral que fue directora de
la reserva federal del banco central y
ahora estar a cargo del departamento del
tesoro será la primera mujer en dirigir
el tesoro en eeuu está también el blog
game primera mujer en ser directora de
seguridad nacional
máximo órgano de seguridad en eeuu ella
había sido directora adjunta de la cia y
asesora adjunta de seguridad nacional
también está la afroamericana
linda toma es greenfield ella será la
embajadora de la onu de eeuu ella tiene
35 años de experiencia y estuvo de
subsecretaria adjunta para asuntos de
áfrica y está también el nombre del
veterano jon que hoy que fue secretario
de estado durante la administración de
barack obama y ahora estará a cargo de
la iniciativa climática será el enviado
especial para temas de cambio climático
en estos próximos cuatro años de joe
biden para responder concretamente a su
pregunta quienes necesitarán la
aprobación del senado pues todos estos
que le mencioné -2 sullivan que será el
asesor nacional de seguridad de la casa
blanca y walker y que será el sar del
cambio climático estos dos no
necesitarán aprobación del senado sin
embargo el resto si lo necesitará esto
vale mientras sigue mientras vayan sigue
seleccionando su gabinete también se
conoce que michigan lo certificó como el
ganador en ese territorio se espera que
de pensilvania también lo haga después
qué puede pasar con las acciones legales
emprendidas por el presidente de donald
trump
pues son acciones legales que han tenido
muy poco éxito de hecho más de 25
demandas han sido retiradas por parte
del equipo legal del presidente de trump
en estos estados en cuestión más de 31
casos perdidos en fuese juicios
electorales y ya de hecho dos oficinas
de abogados reconocidos en el país se
han retirado también del equipo legal de
don otro precisamente para no incurrir
en riesgos de hacer acusaciones sin
fundamento y es que las acusaciones de
donald trump aunque mediáticamente
pueden sonar mucho por el fraude
electoral en los juicios en las cortes
no tienen validez porque carecen de
pruebas y esto ha hecho que donald trump
pues siga perdiendo y mientras tanto
pues los estados siguen certificando las
votaciones en pensilvania pues ya hay
condados que están certificando los
votos de la elección del 3 de noviembre
y se espera que esta noche a las 7 de la
noche se certifiquen los votos de
filadelfia un bastión demócrata se le ha
dado esta ventaja a yo bailé en
sylvania pensilvania entonces con esta
certificación pues le daría ya
completamente la victoria y los 20 votos
electorales al partido demócrata y al
joe baile